.
WE WILL KNOW MORE AND PROBABLY
THE NEXT DAY OR SO.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE CURRENT
PENNSYLVANIA G.O.P. SENATE FRONT
OF HER DR. OZ IS WITH US.
I CERTAINLY WOULD WANT TO BE IN
YOUR POSITION, A CLOSE RACE,
GOING AND WE KNEW THIS WOULD BE
A TIGHT RACE.
THE MOST AMAZING OBSERVATION I
HAVE ABOUT THIS, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE THREE TOP LEADERS AND YOU
LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGES OF VOTE,
ALL THREE RAN AS DONALD TRUMP,
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
CONSERVATIVES.
ALL THREE OF YOU.
NOW, YOU HAPPENED TO GET THE
PRESIDENT'S ENDORSEMENT, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY PAID DIVIDENDS FOR
YOU, BUT WHAT DOES THAT SAY
ABOUT WHERE THE PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA ARE?
I THINK IT IS VERY TELLING.
>> THE PEOPLE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND THE MORE JOE BIDEN IS IN
OFFICE, THE MORE THEY REMEMBER
THOSE HALCYON DAYS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT IF I CAN COMMENT ON THIS
RACE, WE HAVE COVERED ALL
COUNTIES TO ENSURE THE BALLOTS
ARE CURRENTLY COUNTED.
THIS ELECTION IS OUR HOURS.
WE HAVE DONE WELL.
WHAT I WANT TO DO TODAY IS TALK
ABOUT UNIFYING OUR PARTY BECAUSE
THE RUNNERS AND THE OTHER
CANDIDATES ALL WORKED THEIR
TAILS OFF BUT WE NEED TO UNITE
TO TAKE ON FETTERMAN, YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER, I AM PRAYING
HE MAKES A FULL RECOVERY.
AS A HEART DOCTOR TRAINED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA I AM
OPTIMISTIC.
THIS REALLY COMES DOWN TO WHAT
PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA WANT TO.
PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA HAVE A
CLEAR CHOICE.
FETTERMAN'S TO THE LEFT OF
JOE BIDEN.
HE IS NOT EQUAL TO BIDEN, HERE'S
TO THE THE LEFT, SO HE SUPPORTS
SPENDING, RESTRICTING ENERGY,
NUMBER ONE DRIVER OF INFLATION,
I WANT TO LIBERATE ENERGY
PRODUCERS TO REDUCE INFLATION.
DEMOCRATS WANT OPEN BORDERS.
A REAL HOT TOPIC HERE.
I WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE CARTEL
RUN HUMAN TRAFFICKING OPERATION
AT THE BORDER AND SHUT DOWN THE
DRUGS THEY ARE BRINGING IN THAT
MAKES THEM EVEN MORE MONEY.
FETTERMAN WANTS SOCIALIZED
MEDICINE LIKE BERNIE SANDERS.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IF YOU HAVE
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL APPROACHES,
DIDN'T WORK DURING COVID AND
DOES NOT WORK IN GENERAL, I WANT
PRIVATE SOLUTIONS CUSTOMIZED TO
YOUR NEEDS.
HAVE A DOCTOR, SPENT MY LIFE
STUDYING THIS.
I WILL TAKE THESE MESSAGES TO
EVERY QUARTER OF THE
COMMONWEALTH, I PLEDGE THAT COME
INCLUDING PLACES REPUBLICANS,
SEAN, DON'T OFTEN GO.
I'VE GOT FREE CLINICS IN
PITTSBURGH, TAKING CARE OF
THOUSANDS OF FOLKS, SO I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF
WORKING WITH PEOPLE FORGOTTEN.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, YOU KNOW THIS
ABOUT ME, THE HARDEST PART OF
HIS CAMPAIGN, GETTING YOU TO
VENT ME, I HAVE MY CORE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES, A LOT OF
LOVE IN MY HEART FOR FOLKS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE AND
WE WILL PULL THE COMMONWEALTH
TOGETHER AS I CAN PAINT INTO THE
FALL.
>> Sean: I SAID IT AND I MEANT
IT, I DID NOT ENDORSE YOU
BECAUSE WE ARE FRIENDS, I WANTED
TO KNOW THAT YOU WERE AMERICA
FIRST.
I WANTED TO KNOW YOU WOULD FIGHT
HARD AS A CONSERVATIVE, A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN COME
CONSERVATIVE, A TRUMP
CONSERVATIVE, A SAVE AMERICA
CONSERVATIVE AT THIS POINT.
YOU HAVE 87% OF THE VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY IN PENNSYLVANIA,
REPUBLICANS, ARE ALL CLAIMING
THE MAGA MANTLE.
THAT IS A PROFOUND NUMBER.
BUT DR. OZ, WE WILL WATCH.
WE HEARD MATT'S ANALYSIS, WE GOT
YOURS, I DID A LOT OF DIGGING
MYSELF, I AM PRETTY CONFIDENT IN
MY NUMBERS BUT TIME WILL TELL.
WE